>>> CLAIMS OF THE BIG LIE VE
NOT SLOW DOWN.
FOR THE RECORD, THE TEXAS
MIDTERM PRIMARIES ARE LESS THAN
TWO WEEKS AWAY, REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATES ARE STILL SPEWING
LIES THAT THE 2020 ELECTION WERE
STOLEN.
HERE ARE THREE HOUSE CANDIDATES
FROM THE SAME CONGRESSIONAL
DEBATE EARLIER THIS MONTH.
>> I BELIEVE THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
81 MILLION VOTES FOR JOE BIDEN,
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY THE ELECTION WAS
STOLEN.
DOES ANYONE THINK THAT JOE BIDEN
GOT 81 MILLION VOTES?
>> NO.
>> I BELIEVE THERE IS ENOUGH
NEFARIOUS ACTIVITIES GOING ON
AROUND THE COUNTRY, I BELIEVE IT
WAS TAKEN FROM US.
>> WHERE ARE THE EVIDENCE FOR
THAT?
THERE ARE 143 REPUBLICANS
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS IN TEXAS.
THE HOUSTON CHRONICLE ASKS THEM
IF THEY THINK THE 2020 ELECTION
WAS LEGITIMATE.
THE 87 WHO SHARED THEIR STANCE,
ONLY 13 SAID THEY BELIEVE IT
WAS.
42 THOUGHT IT WAS OUT RIGHT
STOLEN AND ANOTHER 12 SAYS THERE
WERE ENOUGH IRREGULARITIES TO
CAST DOUBTS OVER THE ELECTION.
IT IS NOT A TEXAS PROBLEM, IT IS
NATIONWIDE.
>> I AM RUNNING FOR SENATE TO
STOP THE INSANITY AND STOP THE
DAMS FROM STEALING ANOTHER
ELECTION.
I NEED YOUR HELP AND WE'LL HELP
DONALD TRUMP MAKE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN, AGAIN.
>> YOU WANT TO KEEP CORRUPT
POLITICIANS.
>> GEORGIA ARE SICK AND TIRED
AND THEY'LL FIGHT FOR TRUMP AND
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF 2020 AND
FIX OUR ELECTIONS.
IF THEY DON'T DO IT, MIKE
COLLINS WILL.
>> THE BIG LIE EXTENDS FAR
BEYOND THE BALLOT BOX.
>> THIS SHOULD NOT BE COUNTED
AGAINST HIM, HE'S POINTING TO
PUBLIC LEADERS STILL SHIFTING
THIS NARRATIVE.
20 REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES RUNNING
FOR SECRETARIES OF STATE
QUESTIONING THE VALIDITY OF
BIDEN'S WIN.
THEY'RE THE ONES RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADMINISTERING ELECTIONS AND
MAINTAINING OFFICIAL ELECTION
RESULTS.
NOT ALL REPUBLICANS ARE PROPPING
UP THE BIG LIE.
MIKE ROUNDS HAVE THIS TO SAY
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
>> THE ELECTION WAS FAIR AND AS
FAIR AS WE HAVE SEEN.
WE DID NOT WIN THE ELECTION AS
REPUBLICANS FOR THE PRESIDENCY.
>> NO SURPRISE, STATE MINORITY
LEADER MITCH McCONNELL CAME TO
ROUNDS' DEFENSE.
FOR THE RECORD, THE BIG LIE
CONTINUES TO BE THE LITMUS TEST
FOR GOP LOYALTY.
MANY BALLOTS AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT A